and finally to end this piece of the
tutorial I'd like to encourage you to
use your imagination think of lighting
that's not necessarily in the textbooks
look at this for example it's a device
that you'll be seeing a great deal of in
our virtual tool of lighting which
you'll get to later I do not place it on
the light box I use the light box as a
light source as you see in this image
because of its transparency and it's
actually quite beautiful just as
something itself I put it on my flatbed
scanner but this is not a scanned image
I'm actually using the light from the
flatbed scanner as you can see in this
image sometimes it could work when you
get light from the side as it is in this
case and another idea that perhaps you
haven't thought about is to use a small
LED flashlight if you want to image a
very small area of your device here
we're just photographing the spiral
which measures about two and a half
centimeters across all I did was shined
an LED flashlight on to that area around
the area it we get lighting fall off so
we decided only to image this particular
piece in the device this is a image i
started making a material called
ferrofluid and just seeing actually is a
close shot of this material it is oil
that has suspended iron filings I put it
on a glass slide under the glass slide
is a yellow post-it and under the yellow
posted are seven circular magnets and
you're seeing the small iron particles
respond to the magnets it's basically
too tight a shot to see anything of
value in this image I pulled away a bit
and I see a little more of what's going
on but basically the window panes become
may
too much of a distraction and it's not
quite right and so I decided seeing how
reflective the whole image could be to
put a green card above it so now we're
seeing a little bit of green reflecting
off of the material it's just purely an
aesthetic decision it's not clarifying
anything but I'm starting to think that
I might have an interesting image here
and eventually I did wind up with this
final image with the windowpane with the
green card reflecting and if you really
look carefully you see the mistake of a
bad photographer because you see me
although it's fun to play around with
the children and asking them to find
Feliz but this is an image that got a
lot of notice when I made it a while ago
and I was using my imagination in terms
of trying to find a way of using light
in perhaps a different way